Oh what is going on you two now let's
get ready to talk about some real [ __ ]
now if you guys haven't heard of see
this video let's have you guys get a
little taste real quick you see in this
surveillance video the two brothers are
by the counter and the officers come in
they ask me what did I say to them in
the parking lot I didn't say anything I
was talking to my brother and I just
said wow that's crazy they almost hit my
car
I mean my brother said ok and turned
around we thought that was the end of it
but it was not over shortly after one of
the officers asked the guys for ID I
said well what are you gonna do my ID
please you tell me what you're gonna do
my ID and you know tell me what I'm
doing wrong name one thing that we did
wrong in this Coney Island and my
brother like flipped his hands to move
the pushaway and he hit both of us in
the same motion now before we even get
into this let me go ahead and put out a
couple of statements about what I'm a
firm believer that not all cops are bad
and I'm going to stick by that statement
because that [ __ ] is a fact because as
much as I panned her ass have racial
slurs thrown at me and even at a certain
point one cop actually called me a
spiky-haired [ __ ]
I've actually been helped by a handful
of cops as well for me I can't believe
that a few Bad Seeds should be allowed
to represent a whole group in its
entirety
having said that [ __ ] these two cops you
missing chromazone having lopsided lumpy
ball sack mother fuss at it you suck
[ __ ] large gorilla dick that's a
really weird icky stuff cause you got to
lure that [ __ ] without it
killing you was [ __ ] now this video was
sent to me by multiple subscribers so
though I have voiced my opinions about
this I'm not that big into the situation
right now because there has been enough
[ __ ] about police brutality without me
adding fuel to the flame now listen I
also understand that the whole concept
of new media trends and how this right
now is the current hot top down II
enough though a lot of people may or may
not realize the immediate topics are
kind of like how Twitter trends work
with the whole hashtag trending [ __ ] a
school shooting happens and that story
blows up and suddenly for the next three
months all you hear or talk about our
kids who have guns at schools shooting
up the whole campus and now obviously
the
toppings about police brutality so every
other Helen that you see has been about
some kind of miss happening in our
police force in the Centrepointe is news
flash people police brutality and racial
profiling is not something that's view
so yes despite the fact that this right
here is a hot topic of the moment it is
not something that's new and on top of
that it is something that should be
addressed constantly because as of right
now these events that have been
happening have shed a lot of light on
events that people either chose to
ignore or an excuse so no it is not a
case of why law enforcement has suddenly
changed it's a case of why haven't they
now here in this video we have a case of
intelligent versus stupid two cops are
following two black males who suspect
that these cups are profiling and
harassing them and so they ask them a
simple question why and apparently for
some reason this is where they [ __ ] up
because in case a lot of you out there
don't know when a smart person asked an
idiot why and they don't have an answer
they just get mad like how many times
have you asked a dumb answer question
and they automatically assume that you
call them stupid
hey don't wear the bathroom man you
think I can't [ __ ] okay we'll just um
this is a pure example of dumbass Texas
where you throw them a question and they
don't know what the [ __ ] do did to my
suit what
dupa [ __ ] so in this case because
opposites big dingleberry could not give
a real answer to why he was following
him he decided to resort to excessive
violence what a civilian has asked you
why they're being followed and harassed
you should at least have an answer and
if you can't make up one on the spot at
that point just be honest because it
they already know why are you asking for
my ID well because you're cuz you're
black but damn it now I'm also gonna
bring this up too because it's something
that I've noticed a lot recently you
know in a new story it wasn't enough
that they were two black males that were
racially profiled it had to be mentioned
that they were college educated and play
you know it can't just be me but have
you ever noticed that every time there's
a hate crime that's reported it's not
bad enough that it's a hate crime but
now that then college educated oh [ __ ]
oh my god you know I'm not trying to
blow [ __ ] out of proportion but every
time I see this [ __ ] on the [ __ ] news
it's as if saying that they're educated
kind of puts people at ease for me is
kind of like saying the crime was anus
but it's only because they're not one of
those type of black people those type of
Asians or those type of Mexicans is
almost
of saying that the racial profiling that
is used always worth except for this
time it was a little bit wrong because
they were college educated and they
weren't one of those folks now if you
guys don't know I'm from Sacramento
California which is a very culturally
diverse place but when I started
venturing outside of Sacramento is what
I started hearing [ __ ] from people like
you're one of those that speak English
real good and at that point I'll just
have it up and be like actually I don't
speak it good I speak it well I know and
you know what people to a certain point
I get it a lot of it has to do with
ignorance but if a majority of people
out there are stupid and immature what's
going on around them
that is up to us who know better and are
educated to go ahead and teach them
better you know at the end of the day
I'm not here to tell you how to think or
feel I'm just laying down my opinion and
you can even tell me to go [ __ ] off but
when you look at something like this and
all these other cases you're going to
ask yourself this how does that make you
feel
number one I'm going to put up it ah
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]